oh my god
oh god
oh god
oh jesus christ
open it i want to open it alone
getting into yale is very important but
i think it's it's so important to him
because of how important it is to his
mother j.r open it i can't open it i
can't open it's not going to [ __ ]
kill anybody
i am gonna die
the yellow acceptance letter or scene
always sort of like made me feel
emotional when i read it it felt real
and heartwarming in subtle ways in the
editing
mr mcguire
uh
it is a great pleasure to inform you
that the admissions committee has voted
to offer you a place in the yale class
of 1986.
what
it is funny because when they did do the
first take
yeah
and then one note and
it's really is really my favorite scene
in the movie
i'm also pleased to notify you that your
financial need has been met
if you're tricking me i'll kill you
really there's a charm in it but also
there's a vulnerability
it's sort of the climax in many ways of
the
film i
i got an interview yale
your mother must be thrilled
right it is his mother's dreams for him
hopes for him since he was eight years
old she's been saying you've got to get
into yale for her the promised land was
education and so that that was the thing
we are going to get you
into a great school and probably you
know it's not going to be just a great
school it's going to be the greatest
school i swear to god i have no idea how
you are going to harvardy yale so you
can sue your father for childhood no so
he can help you with your fines about
the septic tank he thinks it's
ridiculous his mom
makes 30 bucks a day
how is he going to get into harvard or
yale
you mind if your mama believes in you
no
jr's mother was a bit like my mother she
hasn't been able to go to college
she hasn't made it out in the world
she just wants him to fly in a way that
she was not able to he really sees a
responsibility to prove something to his
mother to go to yale
she knows that this is going to be
right for him she believes it with every
fiber of her being
there's a lot riding on j.r like he's
he's the one uncle charlie could have
left the nest but he had the brains to
do it but you know he didn't do it mom
made bad choice in men i'm gonna be a
lawyer jesus why mom wants me to
talk a lot of [ __ ] and believe anything
so now it's all they're all putting
their energy on to j.r
geez mom what it's okay i don't have
lipstick she's gonna keep saying harvard
yale in law school until she can't
anymore but it's like is he gonna get in
so uh i think it is big moment you know
when he opens that that letter
oh my god it's a really good editor
tanya who's who's editing uh this with
us and we did the cut fat so it was
really slow
and then you start uh
trying to edit it to overlap the
dialogue even more and more and more you
open it that's a call right there she's
the one with the most investors i told
her not to die i don't have a [ __ ]
time so you start with absolutely still
everybody's just quiet listen and then
it explodes they are opening it i can't
open it i can't open
goes really quickly you open no shut up
i can't help you you don't have to dive
give me like oh but i'm gonna die uncle
charlie's a gambler just let him hit the
application fee he opens it and then
there's the silence of waiting
i don't think she she knows until she
knows and she wants it so badly
first time i played it like okay this is
going to be emotional so i you know
it's a trap that actors can fall into
and i certainly are subject to that and
and george said like no no no like have
more fun with it
it is a great pleasure to inform you
that the admissions committee has voted
to offer you a place
yale class of 1986.
what
and then there's this moment of sort of
just release for everybody it's
incredibly moving and surprising i'm
also pleased to notify you that your
financial need has been met
if you're tricking me i'll kill you
really
you know my mom is the hero of this book
and lily playing my mom and doing such a
beautiful job and bringing
her fierceness but also her fragility to
the role the movie has that much more
poignance and resonance for me
[Music]
you could hand in
uh any sort of gold standard scene and
it would come out like crap unless great
actors took it up and somebody like
george was directing
when we first started to shoot it all of
us the actors and myself we were playing
it very cool he was like okay i
shouldn't open and she said you should
open it and i watched it back and i was
like i think this is i think mistakes
are much higher it's why george is so
smart because he knows that you can't go
right at something you have to sort of
somehow approaching something indirectly
makes the audience feel it
then lily starts like i'm gonna die
she took it to 11 immediately and it
made it just
it made it all make sense you know
because she literally was everything she
wanted in life
lily is such a good actor
that she kind of does all the work for
you
if you're smart
you
you just let go
you just want your children to be okay
and you just want them to feel like they
can see a path in the dark
this is known
the head is no
no it's not
every time i read that letter life every
time on camera off camera i felt from
like the same wash of genuine feeling
and george is is you know yes he's an
actor and that's how he started i don't
think people quite recognize how facile
a technical filmmaker he is he gets
he gets it you know and he's he makes
everybody feel comfortable and
i think that's important to the actors
everybody working on this film it's a
simple story right it's just sometimes
it's just about execution
those are the kind of moments that
change families lives
and certainly changed the lives of
all those people in that room